ذَهَبَ اللَّيلُ طَلَعَ الفَجْرُ والعُصْفُورْ صَوْصَوْ
صَوْصَوْ
فَرَأَى القِطَّةَ نَادَها بِسْبِسْ قَالَتْ لَهُ نَوْنَوْ
نَوْنَوْ
بَعْدَ سِنِينٍ مَرَّتْ جُهْدًا عَمَلاً تَحْصِيلا
أَدْرَكْنَا مَطْلَبَنَا المُشْرِقَ بِالعِلْمِ جَمِيلا
حَقَّقْنَا غَايَتَنَا فَخْرًا أَسْعَدْنَا الأهْلَ
مَا أَحْلَى الأَحْلاَمَ الحُلْوَةَ لَوْ صَارَتْ سُبُلاَ
ذَهَبَ اللَّيلُ طَلَعَ الفَجْرُ والعُصْفُورْ صَوْصَوْ
صَوْصَوْ
فَرَأَى القِطَّةَ نَادَها بِسْبِسْ قَالَتْ لَهُ نَوْنَوْ
نَوْنَوْ
نُونُو الشَّاطِرُ صَارَ كَبِيراً حَقَّق غَايَتَهُ
فَوْقَ بِحَارِ الأَرْضِ الزَّرْقَا قَادَ سَفِينَتَهُ
لاَ يَخْشَى هَوْجَاءَ المَوْجِ يَعْرِفُ وِجْهَتَهُ
بِمَوَانِىِء أَقْطَارِ الأرضِ يَصْحَبُ قِطَّتَهُ
ذَهَبَ اللَّيلُ طَلَعَ الفَجْرُ والعُصْفُورْ صَوْصَوْ
صَوْصَوْ
فَرَأَى القِطَّةَ نَادَها بِسْبِسْ قَالَتْ لَهُ نَوْنَوْ
نَوْنَوْ
يُبْحِرُ قُبْطَانًا يَتَأَمَّلُ عِظَمَ نَعَيِمِ اللهْ
مَنْ عَمِلَ بِجِدٍ كَيَّ يَصِلَ لِمُرَادٍ يَلْقَاهْ
لُولُو الحُلْوَةْ كَبِرَتْ أَيَضْاً صَارَتْ دُكْتُوُرَةْ
تَنْفَعُ كُلَّ النَّاسِ المَرْضَى بِالعِلْمِ وَقُورَةْ
ذَهَبَ اللَّيلُ طَلَعَ الفَجْرُ والعُصْفُورْ صَوْصَوْ
صَوْصَوْ
فَرَأَى القِطَّةَ نَادَها بِسْبِسْ قَالَتْ لَهُ نَوْنَوْ
نَوْنَوْ
بِالصَّبْرِ تَحَلَّى كَسِبَ نَجَاحًا فَرَحٌ كَلّلَهُ
أَضْحَى صَفْوانٌ أُسْتَاذًا خُلُق جَمَلَهُ
يَغْرِسُ فِي النَّشْءِ الأَخْلاَقَ جِيلاَ تلْوَ الجِيلْ
لَيْسَ يَضِنُّ بِجُهْدٍ أَبَدًا لِلطَّلَابِ دَلِيلْ
ذَهَبَ اللَّيلُ طَلَعَ الفَجْرُ والعُصْفُورْ صَوْصَوْ
صَوْصَوْ
فَرَأَى القِطَّةَ نَادَها بِسْبِسْ قَالَتْ لَهُ نَوْنَوْ
نَوْنَوْ